and now on to the more interesting crazy
of the conspiracies for which people
will be upset because we're not
conspiratorial enough yes for one person
first evidence of ancient rainforests
found in Antarctica this is awesome this
is from April 1st it's from today and
it's from the most credible sort the
most trusted name in news CNN so means
it must be true okay so it's conspiracy
confirmed it's not an April Fool's yeah
cuz I was looking for news today and I'm
like man how do I know if anything is
real today the worst day in the world
man it sucks so the story itself we have
this medium post showing Admiral Byrd's
flight 1947 where apparently you can go
into the center of the Earth from the
North and South Poles and there's a egg
heart huh oh cool the land of advanced
races a central Sun which kind of makes
the earth seem like a Dyson Sphere of
some sort and then the city of shamballa
but we'll talk about this the first
thing I do want to highlight is that the
story is basically that this dude or
what I was told goes on to Antarctica
and finds like lizard people and fight
some or something but we have the story
about him wins come on
or runs away okay well this is story
from CNN about there were ancient
rainforests found in Antarctica and it's
interesting enough let's read the little
bit of the the real news and then go on
a fantastical voyage they say when
dinosaurs roamed the earth 90 million
years ago the planet was much warmer
including Antarctica at the South Pole
but in a surprising twist researchers
have discovered evidence that Antarctica
also supported a swampy rainforest at
the time according to a new study
researchers captured a slice of the
seafloor using a drill rig aboard a
polar research vessel on west
Antarctica's M a muds Dhin sea between
February and March 2017 the sediment
core sample was taken near the Pine
Island and Thwaites glaciers CT scans of
the sediment core revealed pristine
samples of forest soil pollen spores an
even root system so well preserved that
they could identify cell structures the
soil included examples of pollen from
the first flowering flowering plants
found this close to the South Pole my
heart is incredible very cool they dated
the soil it's fine-grained clay and
290 million years and self 290 million
years ago their study published
Wednesday in the journal Nature
during the initial ship shipboard
assessments the unusual coloration of
the sediment layer quickly caught our
attention
it clearly differed from the layers
above it said Johan Klaas study author
and geologist at the Alfred Wegener
Institute we had found a layer
originally formed on land not in the
ocean scientists know that during the
age of the dinosaurs conditions were
warmer the mid Crysta Cretaceous era
from 80 million to 100 million years ago
was the warmest period for Earth in the
past 140 million years the researchers
said the surface of the sea likely
reached 90 whoa the surface of the sea
likely reached 95 degrees fahrenheit in
tropical areas and the sea level was 558
feet higher than it is now
Wow yes seriously but there has been no
evidence about what conditions were like
in the South Pole
this is the South most sample of the
Cretaceous period collected so far
revealing what Antarctica was like
between 83 and 93 million years ago
conspiracy time yes what if there is an
ancient race that once inhabited these
these Foresti areas 80 250 million years
ago intelligent dinosaur-like creatures
hmm and they struggle to survive in the
pits of the caves and Antarctica and
went to battle with Admiral Richard Byrd
I don't know if that has anything to do
with Admiral Richard Burr anything but
there's this medium post so this is the
first nidalee look one of the first
thing that comes up when you search for
Admiral Byrd and like fighting lizard
people and stuff it's the strange Hollow
Earth case of Admiral Richard Byrd it's
a medium post so it's from Alexandria
Ducksworth I don't know who that is
or whether she's credible or not but
let's uh let's read the story of Hollow
Earth
she writes Medal of Honor recipient
Admiral Richard Ebert allegedly wrote
his encounter with a lost civilization
in Antarctica according to Hollow Earth
theorists Byrd met ancient race
underground in the South Pole how was
this left out from Byrd's mission
operation Highjump could it be one big
hoax conspiracy theorists love to
fantasize according to Byrd's diary the
government ordered Byrd to remain silent
for what he witnessed during his
Antarctic assignment March 11th 1947
quote I have just attended a staff
meeting at the Pentagon
I have stated fully my discovery and the
message from the master all is duly
recorded the president has been advised
I am now detained for several hours six
hours that he none ments to be exact
I interviewed intently by top security
forces and a medical team it was an
ordeal for exclamation point for
exclamation points I am placed under
strict control via the National Security
provisions of the United States of
America I am ordered to remain silent in
regards to all that I have learned on
the behalf of humanity incredible in all
cat all caps
that's how you know it seriously yeah I
am reminded that I am a military man and
I must obey orders not now here's the
question I have is if this is real did
they write in all caps in books like
before the internet I don't know or is
that an internet thing that someone is
like kind of a wink wink at the audience
I did
oMG before there were computers and like
the 1700s they did yeah oh yeah after
many polar accomplishments Byrd
organized
operation Highjump in 1947 the objective
construct an American training and
research facility in the South Pole I
mean that's cool a simple military task
right
some say the American government sent
their troops to the South Pole for any
evidence of the rumored German base
2-1-1 Nazis were fascinated with
anything regarding the Aryan race they
traveled all over the world including
Antarctica to learn more of alleged
origins the Germans did make their mark
in the South Pole however what they have
discovered doesn't compare doesn't
compare to what Byrd recorded in his
diary
Agartha and Arctic cos secret so there's
a flying saucer to Venus apparently
there's uh didn't you know that's where
I was going did he draw this oh yeah
what is this from anyway I don't know
this link this isn't from a person
inside the Hollow Earth via big thing
okay we'll open this one we'll see what
this is that's so cool
center of gravity 400 miles down and
then what you can go inside and walk
like normal or something with a Sun in
the middle of it Shambhala you know one
of the earliest movies I ever remember
seeing I don't remember how old I was I
must have been like three or four but I
was at my grandma's house and it was
Journey to the Center of the Earth and I
remember it being so epic like I was
just like I want to I want to be that
sign
that like discovers the lizards they
they find like dinosaurs massive huge
mushrooms that are like is bigger than
houses and I just I thought that was so
cool I mean I knew it was not real don't
you want this awesome it's like my first
memory of a movie is that wouldn't don't
you want this to be real kinda yeah
would that be it would be amazing
yeah I know that there's like the saying
people say I was born too late to
explore the world and too early to
explore the Stars yeah that's not true
it's just people don't want to explore
the earth they think a lot of the ocean
well they right but also what because
with a satellite picture of certain
islands or certain areas of like
honorable you gotta explore that yeah we
haven't gone up there go go walk around
go to the Amazon walk through the jungle
like people like you'll find stuff hard
work it's crazy there's probably ancient
ruins you've never there there tribes in
the Amazon we've never contacted yeah no
so there's certainly things they
probably have I mean you can get trouble
if you go do that
yes Lee there's a site that I was on and
it helps you identify grave robbers in
like ancient ruins well I don't remember
exactly the name of the site it was
really cool because they basically
crowd-sourced other people to help them
look they would give you like you'd see
this square of and it was a satellite
image of a random place in Egypt or
South America somewhere all these
different places and it they they kind
of teach you how to look for if someone
has been digging like if it was near
like an ancient looking site you would
flag it and then if enough people
flagged it they would go recent go check
it out and it actually worked they
actually started finding people that
were digging in ruins and actually
taking artifacts out of the ground to
try to sell them nice like whatever and
I saw a lot of cool things like it was
so intriguing just to like see snippets
of the earth and you'd see what country
it is but that's all it gave you it's
like it's this country so you know it
was like these old ancient sites well
let's keep reading this but I would
mention I watched this real interesting
YouTube video about how they think they
found where Atlantis was Miss a Hera
desert oh cool because there used to be
coastal yeah and then when it when the
the water is like receded or whatever it
just became
barren wasteland yeah you got by that
tomorrow looks let's let's read this she
goes on for thousands of years people
all over the world have written legends
about Agartha sometimes called Agharta
or agathi the underground city but to
did bird find it he met the master the
city's leader who told him of his
concerns at the surface world quote our
interest rightly begins just after your
race exploded the first atomic bombs
over Hiroshima and Nagasaki Japan it was
that alarming time we sent our flying
machines the flugel rats that sounds
like something out of Rick and Morty
their power ripe Olympus's yes to your
surface world to investigate what your
race had done you see we had never
interfered before in your races Wars and
barbarity but now we must for you have
learned to tamper with a certain power
that is not for your men mainly that of
atomic energy our emissaries have
already delivered messages to the power
of your world and yet they do not heed
apparently the government knew about
Agartha before bird according to the
master places such as Tibet the Great
Pyramid of Giza and the North Pole all
have tunnels leading to Agartha what
else did the master teach bird what
about the rest of operation Highjump
crew high jump crew bird didn't uncover
the underground world alone whether the
whole Hollow Earth story is fact or
fiction
it's great to imagine there are still
hidden civilizations out there in the
world oh it's so it's so interesting
well I tell you what go back to the the
image of the Dyson Earth do you think
flat earthers are out there like I knew
it was something we were we were we
didn't have exactly but this is it no
somewhere look it's it's I mean it's
still a globe but somewhere a bunch of
like middle-aged dudes and glasses walk
into a parking lot with brass knuckles
and chains yeah and then across them
comes another a bunch of dudes with you
know middle-aged guys holding flat earth
you know I'm not gonna call it globe
models yeah and then Nate Wow and they
run towards each other and they're sure
they're fighting chains are flying bats
are swinging someone pulls out a katana
someone's got a pitchfork it's a Dyson
earth no it's flat earth Dyson earth so
inside
hollow earth oh it's the same image
basically yeah so yeah so this is
basically the image that goes around but
here's what here's what we should do
well actually maybe there's a more
recent theories suggest a Hollow Earth
inhabited by creatures that fly UFOs
across our skies or by Dewar --vs
dragons other lost races or ascended
masters and that's what Eric wisdom it's
getting further and further down the
road you know what man it's just
becoming a catch-all for what people
want to exist agar-agar enough hole
right sure well here's the actual
operation operation a person Highjump
the objectives according to the US Navy
report training personnel and testing
equipment in frigid conditions
consolidating and extending the United
States sovereignty of the largest
practicable area of the Antarctic
continent continent publicly denied as a
goal even before the expedition ended
determining the feasibility of
establishing maintaining and utilizing
bases in the Antarctic and investigating
possible base sites
developing techniques for establishing
maintaining and utilizing air bases on
ice with particular attention to later
applicability of such techniques to
operations in interior Greenland where
conditions are comparable to those in
the inductor and Arctic amplifying
existing stores of knowledge
electromagnetic and geological
Geographic hydrographic and
meteorological interesting and
supplementary objectives of the de nuke
expedition and I'll tell you what I
think happened if it's true this Admiral
Byrd guy said all these things isn't it
just more likely that the dude had like
late onset schizophrenia
yeah he was about it gotten really cold
and had some hypoxia and hallucinate how
many people were on the mission with him
a bunch of other people I guess but back
then it was like well I guess it was in
the forties they wasn't that bad there's
a Wikipedia talk about it okay here we
go that let me zoom on if they do bring
it up they do bring up the secret land
the documentary about the expedition the
secret land was filmed entirely by
military photographers and narrated by
actors Robert Taylor Robert Montgomery
and Van Heflin okay so this doesn't have
anything to do with it no it's just like
yeah you go in here and there's nothing
fun you'd think that at least mention it
right yeah because people talk about it
yeah I would I you know it's a it's a
comforting lie it's it's it's fun to
imagine and people want something to be
more exciting that really is
I'll tell you what we're living in
history like you know our friend over
the super chat said yeah we're living
that we're in history books isn't that
weird because to us it seems like
worrying and bothersome history is
condensed yeah so in a hundred years
they're gonna read the whole pandemic
isn't be one paragraph in 2019 you know
this happened in 2021 as they moved on
from the pandemic desolation China you
know there and there was a baby blip
right yep yeah and then as you know in
the 2050s the The Crow Neil's staged a
major uprising yeah they would they
carried the infection and it wiped out
the rest of humans roars thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you